pues su base ha llevado hoy el 70 de los
votos es una proporción enorme y sobre
todo es enorme si se la compara con sus
dos principales rivales el excanciller
fumio kishida y el exministro de defensa
shigeru ishiba ahora realmente sólo
resta el mero trámite de que se lo
ratifique como primer ministro el
miércoles en el parlamento donde el
partido de suba el partido gobernante
del partido liberal demócrata ostenta
claras mayorías la victoria como
mencionabas de sudadera está prevista
por los expertos y en realidad subraya
la intención del partido gobernante de
dar continuidad a las políticas del
dimitido primer ministro shinzo abe
recordemos que durante este último
mandato del psuv ha sido siempre su miel
su ministro de gabinete ha sido su mini
ha sido el ministro portavoz del
gobierno y que junto con su caso es la
única persona que conserva al cargo así
que estamos hablando de la mano derecha
de ave en este caso
andrés dada su cercanía que hay entre su
galla ve que usted nos mencionaba ya
usted lo estaba diciendo puede haber
entonces una continuidad en las
políticas que adelantó sin suave a lo
largo de su mandato esto se traduce en
relaciones muy cercanas con eeuu y una
buena relación también con la unión
europea y mantiene esa atención entonces
con corea del norte
efectivamente lo primero que ha hecho ha
sido ratificar al subrayar que va a
mantener esa continuidad lo cual se
interpreta como cercanía con el
washington con bruselas
obviamente tiranteces con pyongyang con
quien no mantiene relaciones
diplomáticas y espero más allá de esa
promesa la continuidad del mandato de su
hogar también plantea curiosidad y
plantea dudas plantea curiosidad porque
su galeno es un político al uso japonés
no pertenece a ninguna estirpe familiar
es hijo de granjeros empezó de cero en
la política y tampoco pertenece a
ninguna de las grandes digamos los
grandes grupos culés del partido
gobernante eso es algo muy excepcional
la política japonesa por otro lado
plantea dudas porque suba apenas tiene
experiencia en la arena internacional y
porque su perfil público parece parece
tener un perfil más bajo comparado con
ave así que existen dudas sobre si van a
lograr mantener esa calidad de ave y del
partido hasta los comicios de 2021 y
debe hacer frente a la reconstrucción de
la economía japonesa afectada por la
pandemia de kobe 19 muchas gracias
por este informe desde seúl la capital
de corea